si es que detrás de esta acción que
llama al mundo el presidente yo bailén
en temas climáticos hay un ambicioso
plan de infraestructura
este plan infraestructura es de 2
billones de dólares que incluye entre
otras cosas pues 100 mil millones de
dólares para renovar las redes de
distribución eléctricas en eeuu también
más de 170 mil millones de dólares para
impulsar el mercado de carros eléctricos
y miles de millones de dólares más para
la transición a una economía verde para
generar muchos más empleos en eeuu de
hecho allí el énfasis que hace yo bailén
en que la empresa privada se sume a esta
iniciativa y entienda que el cambio
climático es también una oportunidad
económica significativa de hecho jonker
y decía que en la acción hacia el cambio
climático podría representar incluso
pues una bonanza económica más grande
que la revolución industrial yo bailé se
preguntaba si hay alguna otra
transformación en este momento que pueda
generar más empleos masivos
que la transformación la el
direccionamiento hacia una economía
verde sin embargo pues este proyecto de
infraestructura que acompaña a todos
estos cambios climáticos acá en eeuu
tiene que ser aprobada por el senado el
senado que tiene en su medida en la
mitad del partido republicano y que
podría poner trabas para poder pues
impulsar este plan de infraestructura y
estas iniciativas climáticas en eeuu de
ahí entonces que muchos analistas estén
diciendo que precisamente reunir a todo
el mundo reunir a todos estos líderes
insistir en la importancia en la acción
climática para reducir los gases de
efecto invernadero en el mundo pues son
importantes no solamente pues para
lograr la meta de mantener en 1.5 grados
celsius la temperatura del mundo sino
también pues para impulsar este plan de
infraestructura que tiene eeuu en este
país
cristóbal vázquez muchísimas gracias por
este completísimo reporte